I've always been of the opinion that
artists should document the times that
they live in but I also I mean I also
think that artists should make music to
make you dance or make music that
soundtracks your heartache but just at a
time when the political climate was so
messed up and so disturbing it was it
was a shock to me to see that there
wasn't more musicians making political
albums but what's really beautiful is
that actually on the Mercury Prize list
there's a few and then people keep
saying that mine's very
everything-everything they've also got a
political rhetoric present sons of Kemet
have some really brilliant visceral
songs of heavily political as well so
there are I think I'm happy with the
inclusion of a few records which are
also political on the list it depends on
how you measure success and for me like
success was just accomplishing an
instrument being able to make my own
music and record and release an album
but that happened on album one and so
everything since has been a bonus I'm
really not thinking about winning just
having a lovely evening I've got my
parents coming down from the Northeast
I'm just kind of excited to be amongst
this bunch of weirdos